russia's invasion of ukraine has created
a tragedy on the ground and sent a
shockwave through the global energy
system
but all of us can help slow down putin's
war machine
europe's purchase of russian coal oil in
gas sends about 1 billion dollars to the
kremlin every day that softens the
impact of economic sanctions that
western powers have levied on russia
the sum can be cut by reducing the use
of energy voluntarily for example
turning down thermostats by one degree
celsius can cut demand for russian gas
by seven percent in europe according to
the international energy agency
there's even a risk that russia could
stop selling fossil fuels to europe
altogether
or europeans stop importing fossil fuels
from russia to put more pressure on
putin that kind of energy embargo could
bring back days not experienced in rich
countries since 1973. that was the year
when middle eastern oil producers
stopped exporting the fuel to the u.s
and european countries that supported
israel in the yom kippur war
the embargo caused fuel prices to spike
and created a specter that the u.s and
other countries could run out of oil
the fuel crisis need not mean genuine
suffering
for any american
but it will require some sacrifice by
all americans
the u.s government set a national speed
limit of 55 miles per hour and lowered
heating in all government buildings it
even sponsored ads that push the message
of energy conservation
either way
we're going to have to give up something
i suggest we don't be foolish
if energy rations have to be introduced
experts suggest that there are three
things to keep in mind
first people should know the seriousness
of why rationing is being introduced
the wall-to-wall coverage of the war
probably makes that clear
second there should be a condition for
ending rationing
finally the rules of rationing should be
fair and appear to be fair
during the second world war for example
doctors in the uk got more fuel rations
than others because of their duties
climate change hasn't yet led to a large
decline in energy use as scientists say
will be needed
but wars have a way of bringing home
urgency and losing political constraints
including on asking people to make
energy sacrifices
this is net zero i'm akshat rathi follow
us on your favorite platforms
you